hier vom weltall aus ist es leicht zu
erkennen dass die gesamte erde und alle
ihre bewohner einen riesigen
zusammengehörigen organismus bilden und
auch dass diese organismus scheinbar von
einer sich rasch ausbreitenden krankheit
breiten ist
[Musik]
apa
doch nicht es beginnt in der straße dann
ein lager und zehn jahre später ist
alles an regenwald für immer weg
[Musik]
genau dort nicht weit entfernt von einer
der grenzen zwischen tod und leben hat
er sich eine truppe und ermüdet der
naturschützer namens wilderness
international zur aufgabe gemacht die
letzten noch vollständig intakte
ökosysteme dieser erde aufzukaufen und
sie damit vor der sicheren verwüstung zu
bewahren was hat das jetzt mit diesem
video zu tun fragt ihr euch alles fing
an vor einem jahr also ich im rahmen
eines experiments selbst crypto kunst
bzw mfps erstellt habe und das dadurch
entstandene co2 kompensieren wollte das
heißt zum beispiel man pflanzen noch
irgendwo bäume wo noch keine sind damit
die wollen wir dann eben co2 aus der
luft binden können allerdings habe ich
unter einem kommentar von euch
geschrieben bekommt das ist doch cool
werden dass bei well done es
international zu machen und es wäre
natürlich ultra geil wenn diese ganzen
tiere die wir hier so gut finden auch
irgendwann noch ein platz zum leben
haben deswegen habe ich jetzt im
gesamten erlös den regenwald land
beziehungsweise im fall der lang wie sie
das nennen in peru investiert nachdem
über eine million zuschauer dieses video
gesehen haben und sich einige davon
entschieden haben auch zu spenden wurde
die organisation auf mich aufmerksam und
hat uns kurzerhand in den peruanischen
amazonas regenwald am tempo pater fluss
eingeladen um uns das regenwaldgebiet
mit eigenen augen sehen zu lassen dass
wir zusammen mit euch über wilderness
international für immer geschützt haben
ich will den dschungel kennenlernen und
aufmerksamkeit auf seine einzigartige
schönheit sowie seine akute gefährdung
lenken aber auch auf die möglichkeit für
euch über den link in der beschreibung
selbst regenwald zu schützen dafür
möchte ich für 24 stunden einen tag und
eine nacht in aller demut ein teil des
urwalds werden der hier seit 50
millionen jahren steht und hinhören was
er uns zu erzählen hat ich möchte dabei
der natur möglichst nahe sein und
verzichtet daher auf dinge wie ein zelt
einen schlafsack eine regenschutz plane
oder eine hängematte und will auch nur
trinken und essen was der urwald her
gibt es leben alleine auf dieser 100 x
100 meter fläche regenwald mehr wilde
pflanzen und tierarten als in ganz
deutschland teils giftig und gefährlich
deshalb bin ich heilfroh euch vorstellen
zu dürfen der mir jetzt vorm einem
experiment genau zeigen wird was ich
essen will was ich auf keinen fall essen
will und vor allem was nicht ist
kiki ist in dieser gegend aufgewachsen
und beschützt für wilderness
international aktiv dieses
regenwaldgebiet das erkennt wie seine
westentasche schon als kleiner junge hat
er von seinem vater das wissen
vermittelt bekommen wie man da draußen
für mehrere tage und wochen alleine
überlebt und auf unzähligen expeditionen
durch den regenwald die unter anderem
mehrere jaguar begegnungen beinhalten
hat er die gelebte erfahrung die ihn
nicht nur zum perfekten waldhüter macht
sondern auch zum perfekten lehrer mit
dem ich nun zum ersten mal tief in den
dschungel gehen werde abseits aller
pfade
doch noch bevor wir etwas essbares
gefunden haben bringt er mir bereits die
erste unschätzbar wertvolle fähigkeit
bei ein seil zu machen
tatsächlich super spiel also und super
vielen phase und ich so keine reise des
jahres verstarb und so haben jetzt
gesagt wie man mir nichts dir nichts
einfach nicht im kino sah sich
zusammenstürzt dortmund das gerade jetzt
wenn man gespannt was man sonst noch so
alles praktisch anstellen kann außerhalb
sich kein glas darüber bilden da kann
man denen fehlt jetzt essen ist der bus
dann wollen wir mal nicht erst das
probieren
vorne so kommt
man damit kochen wo er muss und deshalb
ballack und der usa
also probieren und
probiere gerne sagen was an sich nicht
aber mit dem expert
verrückt was genau ist das ding
lang ist
[Musik]
kann man die braunen und weißen damit
peronist anregungen von den termiten
werde ich wohl nicht satt aber scheinbar
gibt es in einem gesunden dschungel
wirklich an jeder ecke etwas essbares zu
finden und mit etwas glück ist das was
man gegessen hat noch nicht mal giftig
[Musik]
ist dasselbe
yamamoto
[Musik]
wirkt wie eine sauerei woll verrückt
aber klar sein lieber mangos den voll
zwischen die zähne
ich schaue mir das mal ein bisschen gaga
ist theoretisch muss ich das ja auch
dann selber kennen
also lasse ich von diesen wären wohl
lieber meine finger und keine zwei meter
weiter wartet direkt die nächste
überraschung
es geht da noch was an
das ist ein museum
sind in solchen plätzen oft wieder mal
sie drin oder kann man nicht vorhersehen
oder war es eher zufall dass wieder
rausgekommen sind da war ein passant
realistisch sodass yamamuro
kamin so
verbraucht ein verrückt das ist doch mal
christian laut einfach an jeder ecke
etwas total cool ist das super viele
früchte auch natürlich die noch nie
gesehen habt keine pflanze zwei mal
übertrieben gesagt was das für eine
wilde pflanzen haben die wurzeln hat
über im land hat auch
erste bus kam aus dem sektor cml die im
moment ist aber in den stadien ist ein
ganz kleiner und wie kriegt jetzt
[Musik]
das ist einfach klasse open zu machen
und dann von unten langsam hochdrücken
ist musst du bist so porno sie wir
können ja aufheben als er später mal
zeigen wie man feuer macht dann kann man
die haben schon mal wurzeln des koki
sehrbrock begrüßte
schlaganfälle bruder amir projekt
melodien iss gelangen hier muss das auch
auf und grill seiner spieler wir gehen
das übrigens erst mal komplett ins
nirgendwo wir sie waren darauf den
kleinen pfad kann das ganze gesehen die
jetzt nicht wirklich so aussehen wie der
hier sehen so ein bisschen auch von der
gleichen form ähnlich aus aber viel
perfekter und ich freue mich jetzt
einfach ob ich den auch essen kann oder
nicht doch erst der modelle publikum
also tatsächlich fühlt sich das kann
nicht so hat anders an man merkt ein
bisschen dass ein bisschen härter als
ein bisschen weicher aber
vielleicht sollte ich doch von pilzen
bisschen sich
intel appup
an
silvester
also keine panik aber hier
ist sogar minimal ist noch die alimente
community benaglio fressen dass menschen
auch da haben wir ein problem auch nur
so groß ist die
quelle
[Musik]
rodgau hunger des privatmanns die
behandlung eines super sketch einmal
irgendwo im dunkeln konnten muss ich das
weltgeschehen
wahlkreis warendorf ist in solchen ist
einfach da
was vor allem daran liegt dass es in
deutschland so gut wie keinen echten
urwald mehr gibt umso kostbarer ist der
intakten urwald hier im amazonas den wir
jetzt zusammen über den link in der
beschreibung mit wilderness
international beschützen können dieser
wald ist seit über 50 millionen jahren
hier 50 millionen jahre in dem sich
einzigartige pflanzen tiere und
symbiosen entwickelt haben die wahrheit
ist leider wenn man nichts unternimmt
würde all diese entwicklung in den
nächsten zehn bis 20 jahren einfach
vernichtet werden auf die politik in
südamerika kann man leider nicht hoffen
deshalb ist will das international zu
unterstützen meiner meinung nach
wirklich das mit abstand beste was man
tun kann und seitdem ich vor ort gesehen
habe wo genau unser gespendet das geld
hingeht und wie das team damit umgeht
hat sich diese meinung nur verstärkt ein
euro schützt ein quadratmeter regenwald
der dann eure trägen unsterblich ist
selbst wenn irgendwann die ganze welt
mit bulldozern den einkaufszentren und
parkplätzen verwandelt wurde gibt es
trotzdem noch gesunde ursprüngliche und
uralte natur auf diesem planeten und das
dank euch ich finde den gedanken extrem
schön außerdem werden mit dem ein euro
pro ein quadratmeter lokale waldhüter
wie jacky bezahlt die aufpassen dass dem
dunkel nichts passiert ihr dürft nicht
vergessen dass der wald in diesen
gebieten nicht hauptsächlich von
riesigen konzern abgeholzt wird sondern
von einfachen bauern die keine andere
möglichkeit haben wilderness
international versucht deshalb alle mit
ins boot zu holen und zeigt deshalb
nicht mit dem finger auf leute die von
und auf diesem land leben müssen will
denn es international deren fast
gesamtes team wir hier übrigens
kennenlernen durften möchte vielmehr
möglichst vielen lob ist die möglichkeit
geben davon leben zu können irland mit
ihrem unfassbaren wissen zu schützen
anstatt dinge tun zu müssen die sie
eigentlich nicht tun wollen wie
waldrodungen und illegale goldgräber
reihe mit quecksilber um ihre familien
unterstützen zu können so ähnlich ist
auch die geschichte mit dem es jetzt
seit er durch den turm geht nicht im
bilde was findet am boden
also am besten
ich
bin doch gas weil man es halt einfach
essen ich weiß ich dass ich glaube es
ist schlimmer aus wenn ich nichts weiß
ist oder gar
das ist eine gute idee darin zu schlafen
weil es sieht aus wie das
[Musik]
casa de los wenn ich denn jetzt nicht so
uncool finden ideen wie kann ich denn
sonst irgendwie wir haben in ihr habt ja
eine unterkunft bauen und die abdichten
pleite gegen ring
[Musik]
movassat atlanta pte
wenn ich mal schauen wie man daraus ein
bett jetzt zaubern will schlecht geht
jetzt quasi diese ganzen blätter die
größeren
zusammenhält
und
das
ist auch gut doch wie finde ich im
regenwald wo der regen der das holz
feucht macht ja schon im namen steht
trockenes brennmaterial um ein feuer zu
starten
oder viel kleinholz
[Musik]
naja ist
zu behalten oder wie es dann ist man
zwischen zwei stöcke gepackt damit ich
halt nicht abbrennen
das ist über künstliche wurden
superschnell
er schmeckt wild ist okay es ist
tatsächlich okay sind nicht geil das
geht
dann kannst du kannst ihn zu wissen ist
nicht so schlimm wie man denkt ein
bisschen was zu essen kenne ich jetzt
schon mal was allerdings noch viel
wichtiger sein wird als essen zu finden
ist sauberes trinkwasser ich werde
gerade dafür vorbereitet 24 stunden im
dschungel zu sein und da brauche ich
zwei energie aber überleben würde ich es
auch ohne essen doch bei tropischer
hitze keinen einzigen schluck wasser zu
trinken würde schon nach wenigen stunden
zu einem ernsthaften problem werden und
könnte zu die hydrierung führen
wieder trifft
sie zeigt mir also diese liane sie
speichert wasser ist sogar transportabel
und wächst leicht wieder nach wenn man
sie richtig erntet sie ist also
nachhaltiger als jede wasserflasche
crazy
herauskommt
dass es so viel also eine liane wirken
auf die siegreichen für den ganzen tag
eigentlich kann man so viel trinken ich
will oder ist das irgendwie ab einer
gewissen menge technologie dafür bist du
es tun erlernen ist
dass man sich aus wirklich dass der
trick aber ersten kann es nicht
ich habe leute mit nina hoss
not you can have much
ich hab das jetzt gegessen es brennt
recht nur den mund aber nur das letzte
stück
also das eine ganz andere schärfe ich
habe jetzt bisschen zu weit runter
gegessen sondern ich bin zu essen das
ist wirklich
mein gott also wenn wir das im dunkel
passieren würde würde ich sofort
abbrechen weil das ist schon echt krass
gerade das ist nicht mehr chef also das
komplette
wissen wir probieren wiederum schmeckt
davon dass ich die finger weg das ist
krass ich kann ja nicht mal richtig
reden das ist echt so schlimm dass nicht
ausgelacht
wenn ich jetzt das so spüren würde ich
mir denken ich muss sterben 100 wenn ich
es nicht besser wüsste dass auch eine
erfahrung
wenn ich darf mich nicht mit einer
pflanze zu vergiften bleibt aber noch 1
offen was alles gibt es da draußen das
mich essen beißen vergiften oder stechen
könnte um diese überlebenswichtige frage
zu beantworten habe ich mir den biologen
dr chris kirk beat der seit 25 jahren
genau in dieser region forscht und
natürlich jackie geschnappt und sie
kurzerhand gefragt
[Gelächter]
dann lesen sie wo das minus im zug die
lachende
wohnungseinbrüchen
es gibt alles gibt es schlangen raupen
ameisen spinnen
katzen dh ich habe jetzt auch glaube
nicht die zeit genau zu lernen wie jetzt
zum beispiel die schlange aussehen so
weiter und so fort das heißt ich will
mich einfach mal vor allem schlangen
vorhandene raupen vor allem spinnen
bisschen fern halten aber er sollte es
trotzdem so weit kommen dass ich jetzt
irgendwie schlange see oder einen jaguar
was sehr unwahrscheinlich ist aber wie
sollte
[Musik]
im interview mit humana
was er mag
die halle gehen weiter
so blieb das nun ebenfalls
dezimierten und freunde des boulevards
hat der mieter die
wasserprobleme kilo pro ps energie
transfer bis känguru das ding ist wie
man
sieht ist
dass
ich weiß jetzt sicherer fühlen soll
vorbereitet okay
was mit diesem wissen werde ich im
zweiten und letzten teil dieser reihe
mit dem boot am fluss ausgesetzt und
möchte dann einen tag und eine nacht
mutterseelenalleine im urwald verbringen
mir ein bett bauen und nur das essen und
trinken was ich mit meinem leben
gelernten wissen auf eigene faust finde
bis ich dann nach 24 stunden an
derselben stelle wieder abgeholt werde
sofern ich sie wieder finde dieses
finale erscheint in wenigen tagen auf
diesem kanal ich bin gespannt wie viel
quadratmeter regenwald wir bis dahin als
community mit wilderness international
über den link in der beschreibung für
immer geschützt haben 16 quadratmeter
kompensieren zum beispiel den
monatlichen co2 ausstoß eines
durchschnittseuropäer sven ihr wollt als
einmalzahlung oder auch passend im
monatlichen rhythmus mit 35 quadratmeter
könnt ihr eine fläche schützen so groß
wie eine ein zimmer wohnung tatsächlich
genauso groß wie meine erste eigene
wohnung und 134 5 meter kompensieren ein
langstreckenflug für zwei personen für
den flug nach büro und zurück habe ich
also für mein team direkt 400 ausgewählt
wenn ihre schüler sagt schlak teurem
lehrer doch mal vor dieses video
anzuschauen und als schulklasse 300
quadratmeter zu schützen das würde
nämlich eure klasse klimafreundlich
machen samt schulweg klassenfahrt strom
und ich kann mir kaum vorstellen dass
jemand wirklich verrückt genug ist mit
6400 quadratmeter die fläche eines
ganzen fußballfeldes zu schützen aber
ich werde die verrückten von euch da
draußen auch nicht davon abhalten die
option gibt es übrigens natürlich
allesamt spendenquittung und dadurch
deutlich absetzbar wir sehen uns in teil